well
here we are how's it going reject nation
my god this just
it just doesn't stop with that does it
no
no the dceu is in great shape especially
with its casting beyond that this story
is
horrifying now the flash is on the run
i'll never catch them so yeah i mean
we're gonna talk about this weird
situation with uh
dakota iron eyes we're also gonna share
why we unfortunately don't think that
ezra will be getting fired anytime soon
and why ezra miller is missing no one
knows where to find the individual
here's the long story short of what's
going on there's this individual out
there 18 year old dakota iron eyes
miller has been accused of physically
and emotionally abusing dakota by her
parents to quote here's what it says uh
psychologically manipulating physically
intimidating and endangering the safety
and welfare of their child the term
being thrown around right now i believe
by the times was grooming their child
because apparently ezra met dakota when
dakota was just like 12 years old and at
the time ezra was 23 years old and
they've developed a relationship that
has gotten closer and closer and closer
ever since so there was an interim order
of protection that was uh filed they
just need to serve it to ezra miller but
they can't find ezra miller basically
the order would bar miller from
contacting or harassing the 18 year old
or their parents and also would force
them to stay a hundred yards away from
the family residence prior to a july 12
hearing walt dakota who now has the last
name gibson who is believed right now
believed to be missing with miller right
now at this time so the court documents
the family file alleged that miller
exhibited behavior in a pattern of
corrupting a minor that they took an
immediate and apparently innocent liking
to dakota iron ides and displayed
cult-like and psychologically
manipulative controlling behavior and
there's a more horror stories that are
yes alleged that miller gave dakota
alcohol marijuana lsd in florida places
like new york california london vermont
and hawaii so this is all coming off of
the heels of everything ezra miller's
already done with destroying the lives
of people in hawaii as of late first off
you know like i'm aware that this dakota
individual did go on social media and
was basically saying like i can't
believe this is happening this is my
world my choices and i'm like girl this
is you sound like someone who has been
groomed right now
like maybe
maybe you're right maybe but this also
lines up with someone who is now
six years with some very important parts
of childhood development to become
attached to this older individual who
probably gave you some illegal
substances and has been controlling your
mind along the way to make you it sounds
like cult like following behavior i
don't know for sure look i don't mean
this in any disrespect to the trans
community what i'm about to say right
now i really don't we do our best to
adhere by the pronouns just out of
respect so i'm trying to take this from
the perspective of something like i
don't have a daughter i have a sister um
but imagine if you have a daughter or
you have a younger sister you're like
learning that
my 12 year old daughter
is friends with this 23 year old man
yeah and is hanging out with them and
talking to them all the time they're
going on trips and they're doing all
these things and she's changing as a
person she won't stop her friendship
with him and he has no desire to stop
the friendship
and clearly he's clearly obviously what
did you say like this is messed up like
that is a messed up oh all that alone
even if not all of this is true it's so
inappropriate it is such an
inappropriate relationship it is and it
makes you wonder where again the line is
that allowed the situation to spiral to
this extent because too i mean we've
seen this with a lot of other people's
cases that celebrity is very
intoxicating even for parents there are
a lot of things that you let slide
because you know somebody famous and
with status is taking an interest in
your kid or whoever that you might not
let slide otherwise and that makes me
afraid too in this conversation because
maybe this could have been avoidable
if it hadn't been a situation involved
with somebody of ezra miller's stature
in the public eye you know bottom line
this is just a really messy situation
i'm like how can they not find ezra
miller this is insane i know miller is a
really reasonable person yeah what kind
of secret agent are they because there
are only so many places to hide him and
i mean maybe they've left hawaii all
together i mean i don't know exactly the
circumstances of where and when they and
dakota meet each other or whatever over
this long-standing relationship but yeah
this does not sound good and i mean to
hear the parents talk you could always
argue that there's a he said she said
you know maybe they just want to control
their you know kids life but at the same
time even the statements that have been
released from dakota themselves it all
uh it all smacks of a bad situation i
don't know i feel like the only reason
ezra miller is not being fired is simply
because they have a movie that they need
to release that's already shot and as
well into post-production it was
supposed to come out this year and so
the whole process of all the money
involved i think wb right now is just
going look we just got to keep ezra
miller out of the press just don't let
ezra do any promotions whatsoever even
for the flash just have ezra avoid any
and all questions i believe that wb is
somehow hiding ezra miller from all this
just so they could release their movie
by this point that's the part in the
development stage right i think ezra
absolutely should be fired it's a weird
feeling to be in right now because
there's a part of me that's like yeah i
still want to see andy muschietti's the
flash i still want to see those batman
on screen i still want to see supergirl
like there's so many more people than
ezra miller involved in that movie that
is such a grabber for me of why i want
to see this film the same time moving
forward ezra better be getting fired
after this movie comes out and the only
reason i think ezra hasn't been fired is
because they got a movie to release and
just think about what the press leading
up to that would be it would make the
flash feel unimportant knowing that okay
this person's not going to be the flash
anymore it would just create all this
more negative attention that their main
star is already creating for the film
like imagine watching the trailers and
the whole time the audience is like that
person's fire you know yeah and just
sitting here and thinking about all of
this and all the other situations and
blemishes that have followed ezra
miller's public career i'm fascinated to
know when the shoe is gonna drop where
the line is because this seems like
something where at very least even if
the flash movie comes out and even if
it's revealed that ezra miller is maybe
not quite as uh
responsible for all of these criminal
allegations as it sure seems like they
are like i can't imagine a future beyond
this movie for them and it seems like at
a certain point they're gonna have to
commit to coming out and terminating
their involvement but i don't know how
they can release this movie now like it
doesn't seem as important to me as
figuring out the truth even though i
know that millions upon millions of
dollars ride on it and the future of
their franchise rides on it but
especially on the heels of everything
with johnny depp and amber heard and now
this is a really ugly situation that i
don't really see any kind of good end to
and i'm just again like
how
far and why does the money machine reach
and if they do decide to put this movie
out how are people going to respond to
that because i have to imagine that the
more these kinds of reports come out
about ezra miller the less people are
going to want to support that movie and
i feel like this is perhaps one of the
easiest instances of being able to look
at someone and what they're doing in
their personal life and go hey maybe we
ought not to support that and give it a
platform you know yeah so yeah guys like
i don't think anyone who's like going as
or should be fired i don't think
anything about ezra being fired until
that movie's out if it does happen then
kudos it's a weird position to be in as
just a fan of looking forward to the
flash movie it's a weird position to be
in but that doesn't matter
right now what matters is
these
people who are at
the suffering end of what ezra miller
does whether that be these emotional
psychologically abusive relationships or
these physical assault instances in
public these are the people to be
concerned about at a certain point i'm
like you sure get ezra miller whatever
help ezra miller needs to get but
there's
these people right now matter they they
they need help they need help and so if
you have to sacrifice a movie you
sacrifice a movie yeah yeah because
there's just way too much of this to not
suggest that there's something serious
going on with ezra miller that needs to
be addressed and yeah i think giving at
least a bit more credence and and and
time and care to how would you say
credence right now
you're always going for that
zinger where did you go oh he's looking
for a good opportunity it's right now
uh you know
it'll all be it done in a flash but we
need to talk about kevin
we need to talk about ezra i'm
fascinated to see how this shakes out
but i think there does need to be a good
amount of attention given to these
people's stories and to the situations
that has been left in ezra miller's wake
because clearly again a lot of people
are are having these experiences to the
point where i'm like it can't just be a
misunderstanding it can't just be some
kind of conspiracy or whatever like
there's something really wrong here all
right
well damn never thought we'd be talking
about this yeah i didn't think this
would be the development of the ezra
miller story you guys remember
potentially groom and kidnap somebody oh
my gosh no just messed up guys what do
you think
are you team ezra leave your thoughts
down below
uh we'll talk to y'all later thank you
for being here
[Music]
you